[Music]
Dead Alliance is a team-based tactical
shooter with the unique hook of there
being a huge amount of zombies in the
middle messing everything up unlike many
other first-person shooters that have
zombies in them the aim of the game is
not to mow down as many zombies as you
can the whole point is to use a zombies
as a tactical weapon against your enemy
you can use very special weapons that
we've developed in the game that you can
either turn them into attack dogs for
your team for example or you can use
them as defensive shields it adds a very
very unique tactical hook to the to the
game making pretty different from most
first-person shooters you ever going to
play so the story in Dead Alliance takes
place in the future after the zombie
apocalypse has already happened what we
have left now is already these warring
military paramilitary factions we're
fighting over the resources that are
left but in that they have also found
out how to control these zombies using
various pheromones and noises there are
more in quantity of the zombies they're
an easier thing to use then you know
using things like bullets or mo or
grenades you don't want to waste that
stuff that stuff's extremely valuable
but when you have lying around you have
a bunch of zombies there let's take that
let's use that this whole concept
creates a strategic challenge that will
pull you in and keep you on your toes
[Music]
it's always fun to actually get a kill
on somebody else with your weapon but
it's extremely satisfying when you are
able to weaponize a zombie and it ends
up taking down three people really it
kind of makes you rethink the way you
play a first-person shooter I mean
there's guys we play against in the
office that are great at shooting but I
have an advantage over them because I
know how to weaponize a zombies the most
direct way to just weaponize a group of
zombies when they're near an enemy and
they will help take down that enemy
while you're also attacking them
yourself or even block an enemies egress
into or out of a building so for example
if you know that there's an enemy or a
team of enemies inside a building you
can you can send a group of zombies into
that building to either flush out your
enemy or to kill them outright
so it's really finding what combinations
of items work well together there's a
Pamprin aid that you can throw out the
zombies and get some super mad and they
will be hyper aggressive I've seen
people use zombies as kind of a wall so
they'll use the LRAD which basically
attract zombies into an area so that the
snipers and the enemies at a distance
couldn't really attack them so they had
to pick off a wall of zombies at first
and so it really just creates a more
dynamic battlefield for players to
experience
in any first-person shooter teamwork is
a cornerstone of the experience but with
debt alliance they get to push even
further having three other team members
on your team makes it far easier to send
cohesive instructions to them and
coordinate your attack patterns as well
as your defensive perimeters so keeping
it to a 4v4 experience you have a
tighter knit team and also thematically
there's not many humans left because
every zombie there are modes that many
players will recognize such as capture
the flag team deathmatch there's there's
a free-for-all mode so in the example of
capture the flag you're not actually
just moving a capture flag from point A
to point B you're actually picking up
this canister of zombie pheromones and
as soon as you pick it up interesting
things happens with the zombies like now
they react differently to you and we
want to add a unique mode that's never
been seen before and we hit upon the
idea of maybe borrowing from a mobile
game creating a special map just for
this mode so attrition mode is each team
has a base that they spawn at and
there's two different lanes on the map
and sort of a jungle area in the middle
players need to work down those lanes
and capture tower point and back at
their base they have a constant stream
of friendly zombies spawning out and
attacking those lanes with them there
are still a bunch of neutral zombies
throughout the map that they can then
influence and work to their advantage
and in the middle jungle area we have
some high-level special zombies that
will give your team boosts if you kill
them a health boost or defense boost the
goal is to push the enemies Lane all the
way back at least one of them and then
attack their final base and once you
destroy that base you've won the match
single player in Death Alliance has two
different versions you can play
completely offline but instead of
playing against human players you have
BOTS we also have a dedicated
single-player mode called solo survival
that plays like a horde mode that's a
series of levels that you go through
zombie waves will just continuously
attack and continuously attack and
there's other environmental hazards like
gas that have been dropped that are
forcing you to certain locations and
each map tells a next chapter of the
story essentially I won't give anything
away but you basically have to fight
your way through the levels and find out
what happens
[Music]
we'll see you on the battlefield